e chi odia il contrario cosa ti blocca
in tutto questo momento no vabbè ho
capito c'è che
abbiamo fatto i nuovi siamo due
hanno abbastanza di noi
[Musica]
ciao ragazzi benvenuti ad una puntata di
vita buttata questa chiacchiera oggi me
la faccio insieme a voi e al mio
amichetto giancarlo con mare ciao
essere passato a grazie a te per il
cambio di capello perché sto facendo
jamie al teatro brancaccio che è già
uscito in realtà ma questo qui diciamo
lamentata inception ancora non sappiamo
com'è andata li tratta per me inizia
domani funzionando come se come la sto
cavando sotto ovviamente questa paura di
fondo soprattutto per il canto dato che
io non sono un cantante da due mesi
soltanto che studio per fare questa cosa
sono stato un cafone non ti offerto
nulla da bere
tutto analcolico naturalmente io tanto
non posso be roma fi l'alcol creare il
flusso non fumo più anch'io non fugge
questa quanto non è un mese anch'io
bravo un ottimo banco se voi e l'ho
fatto per dieci anni si mette dentro
intanto ti servo
che non te lo so è una piccola città che
abbiamo implementato quest'anno perché
non avendo più contenuti abbiamo detto
che dovevamo
perché lo sto girando siccome non ho mai
capito esattamente come funziona ragazzi
come sempre me lo ricordo tutta questa
roba è analcolica quindi prima che si
pensi male
ciao ciao spero molto veloce festa del
mio paese quindi c'erano 350 miliardi di
persone in giro si sa quando indossa una
gonna 4 bianco cosa può succedere no non
era il circolo genere di comparare che
cosa fu social eticamente migliore da
fare una cuccetta io la faccio solo che
non era una puzzetta maniera cieca sorta
questo è proprio quello che si chiama
effetto seppia venuta in mente una cosa
che è successa a un mio con collina non
se lo posso dire insomma ha incontrato
una ragazza erano una situazione un po
ubriachi tutti questi sono andati a caso
tutto quanto stavano per lei si
addormenta molto carini si abbracciano
così si addormenta lui la mattina si
sveglia e si sente il braccio come se ci
avesse un po sbagliato si del liquido
sul braccio e aveva il braccio
completamente pieno di merda o anche tu
il belletto
di merda ha fatto un po il signore
quindi si è alzato da te in bagna se poi
sono alla svegliata torna in camera
pulisce senza svegliarla questo qui non
lo disegno dello scoperto ulissi ma poi
quello che c'era attorno a questa
ragazza cioè le file peer in
eschilo porta tutto insomma lavare carta
tutto quanto era giustamente lei stava
lì con le lenzuola la banda nella sua
stessa merda se ne va a sbrigare stesse
cose torna lui era scioccato lo racconta
i suoi conquilini se con corini iniziano
a ridere io credo che questa cosa
sveglia la ragazza si alza verso la
camera e trova lei con il fagotto di
lenzuola piena di merda di fatti o
cagate tutto il letto
questa ragazza se n'è andata in taxi
piangendo perché voleva lavarle le
coperte cioè tu pensa il tassista ma col
fa cose sono andate così disperato e
morello se fossi stato in lui avrei
fatto la seguente cosa preso il
materasso chiuso con tutta la ragazza
dentro
inceneritore più vicino
ero con questo ragazzo che era tipo la
verità è una ragazza di 15 anni capire
un cazzo mi sa che lontano ivan cazione
minuti quando poi sono andate a farlo
semplicemente le statali ti piace ti
piace ti piace mi piace magari del buco
un cazzo fa io non ho capito la dinamica
accesse una queste sono le gambe ok e
qui alla fine abbiamo diciamo l'ingresso
cosa ti blocca in tutto questo momento
da questa pagina
no ragazzi io la mia prima volta la
ricordo molto bene è stato come magari
era butteremo chiodi al contrario un
qualcosa di atroce e vi giuro che non
stava nemmeno con eco zam col
prima volta un mese è stata bella ma era
la prima volta anche per lei mi hanno
detto di sì poi dopo mi ha confessato
che in realtà non aveva mai fatto sesso
ma va fatta penetrare con le dita già
ma quindi andiamo avanti
vi racconto la mia prima ubriacatura la
nostra viola comes eravamo quattro
amiche e ci siamo aprirete di brutto poi
siamo tornati stanza io dormivo nel
letto a castello sopra naturalmente
appena mi sono sdraiato
commissione dall'altra parte della
francia presi quando sopra ho centrato
in pieno la borsa nuova editrice campana
della mia amica determinati soprattutto
canestro non sa che è stata simile alla
mia prima volta sono tagli e solo per
fare uno stage di dams mi danno questa
cosa inizia a sbarellare l'ho fatto in
balcone praticamente vomitando sull'a6
le tende quelle sì certo della vicina da
sotto ma 8 in quei volti conosciuti come
buono però la più brutta credo sia stato
quando ho passato la notte nudo successo
e noi con qui no è arrivato e mi ha
spostato il gioiello di no no no a un
altro ne ha scostato sull'idea di
chateau sente una prova dormirei of mi
sono svegliato nudo sul bidet l'inganno
non potremo montare nulla però così
perché doveva essere italiani giudicano
con questo ragazzo 15 anni circa 10
molto ansioso non si fidava dei classici
metodi precauzionali usati da chiunque e
quindi
diversi momenti di discussione mi
propone di usare oltre il preservativo
un bel giro di pellicola non ci credo
po come faceva la zia di una mia
campagna con un cetriolo perché tu hai
un aneddoto per ogni cosa che ha fatto
questa qui costate compari e raccontato
che una sua zia faceva questo con un
cetriolo cioè sofia si si accoppiava con
gli ortaggi avvolti nei passati nel
microonde non è vero che non c'è secondo
me questa questa cerca solamente di
farsi accettare a voi che magari eravate
ai figli muoio frigo non era vero quello
diciamo un po lizzato io venivo
utilizzato ci sta più e professori e dei
compagni c'era questo professore che
perché dicevo che volevo fare l'attore
ha rigirato tipo per i corridoi perché
non dovevano in bagno faceva entrare
nella casa della giovane faceva a
bollate lui vuole fare l'attore è quale
sarà la futura nullità visualizzare in
questo modo che cosa è successo quando
invece il successo di ha trovato piccola
sto dicendo lui fa anche il
il direttore di un giornale locale
quando non ci credo ho fatto la mia
prima cosa in tv e sono tornato a casa
quell'estate mi ha incontrato e lui mi
ha chiesto di un'intervista per il suo
giornale però io lì in maniera molto
dotato c'è anche chi facendo finta di
tirarle non poi scusi non concede
interviste ai giornali locali
mi complico la mia rivincita
[Applauso]
no è inutile che applaudono le
lemano perché se tu avessi veramente
superato il problema tu mi avessi detto
certo i giovani però molto giovane
probabilmente adesso ha mai fatto una
minchiata pacco
io non la ricordo minimamente
facciamo il segmento e titti il comodo
ok non posso davy devi della nostra lo
sporco col nome di cercato mezzo mondo
scolastico si gialle cos'è pagina con
rimmel perché questo punto è solo quello
può essere
un secondo
che vi racconto questo aneddoto per
lanciarti poi un giochetto che voglio
fare insieme a te quando teatro e questo
curo spiego a voi non a giancarlo sta
male un attore e più delle volte c'è
un'altra persona una cover che scala e
prende il suo posto quindi andiamo a
l'aquila in questo posto a fare crisi ci
viene a rivedere il regista una delle
ragazze però si era fatta male e quindi
f1 si chiama f1 diciamo lance humble
femminile ottiene finalmente ruolo e
della sua occasione di far vedere quanto
vale ma al regista che insalata
taratata si ribalta e sento con qualcosa
di strano e mi tira non capisco cosa
penso che sia il magnetismo che c'è tra
di noi e il passo iran sta si è
trasformato in un cane imbizzarrito si è
ritrovato con la parrucca attaccata al
mio bottone ha quindi la mia giacca
tirava tutta di lato e quindi pubblico
vedeva questo logo l'occhio proprio la
barocca fino a qua sembrava il conte
dracula
con tutti i ricci che partivano
solamente dalla lui lei sinistra mi fa
ti prego
e dalla sala sentiamo una sola voce che
sbotta reader ed era saverio marconi il
regista va presa bene dall 8 giugno 2020
io le mandavo a questa ragazza questo
messaggio
[Musica]
[Risate]
qual è la cosa importante da fare è
riuscire in due secondi attore delle
soluzioni avremo delle domande e dovremo
rispondere 5 se con della domanda
secondo me questa qui è la stessa
prospettiva che hanno utilizzato per
fare gli effetti speciali tra gandalf e
frodo
dimmi 3 bugie che hai detto ai tuoi da
ragazzo non mi masturbo sono etero mi
piace la cioccolata
per lui è un pezzo operoso che ne sapete
se mi piacciono una cioccolata davo
dimmi te cose che fai a letto
[Musica]
dormo
io l'ho detto dormire e riposare sognare
capo come la notizia del mio coinquilino
abbiamo
ha perso
5 secondi aveva io tanto caro al
montaggio ai
team i tre cose che fai nel tempo libero
dormo
dimmi tre riti che ha in prima di salire
sul palco faccio le corna a tre volte a
sinistra bevo
controllo tutti gli oggetti
mi masturbo
in tre cose che fai in prima mattina il
test scrivo mi metto la copertina calda
e mi metterò a doverti nella calda non è
veramente perché non l'ho messo bene no
una copertina è riscaldata
per capi di abbigliamento che indossi
sempre una maglia mutande calzini vabbè
ho capito c'è
tre agenti di menton carlo talentuoso
bellissimo
poi ci sarà un bip tutti si chiederanno
che cosa avevo diritto e tutti ridono
quindi quasi il contenuto giancarlo tre
cose che fai quando nessuno ti guarda
l'ostacolo
dito che piedi
[Musica]
questo è stato chiaramente comunque
sbagliato e va beh
chi è che sta vincendo
per farti capire qui elmo nomina tre
codici senza cui non esci di casa
mutande calzini una maglia
di tre cose che dirette ad un estraneo
in fauna
che caldo e stesso dando delle belle con
l'asciugamano
ragazzi che siamo due
anni tre cose che diresti a qualcuno che
trovi attraente bono back oppure una
pecora
[Applauso]
scusa per essere in ritardo e ho fatto
tardi e
non ho capito
le cose che sono grandi
della terra le imprese building il mio
ego
zaccardo oggi questo non piccole
il suo cane
[Musica]
mamma mia non riuscivo proprio mandato a
casa in lacrime il suo cane le formiche
in tre modi per dire fare all'amore
chiamare buga buga
ultima ultima ultima per giancarlo e
delle canzoni che canti sotto la notte
da brividi
[Applauso]
adesso tutte quelle di jamie
spotlight
segreto
tubetto signori è stato un piacere per
gli esami
che ha vinto quindi trovare
[Musica]
uno di quelli che decidiamo di aspettare
biciclette solo che io non so andare in
bicicletta risultato lungomare di
gallipoli me con tre macchine
parcheggiate più una moto parcheggiata
il tizio stava ancora parcheggiando la
moto e di fortunatamente incollando la
moto ben collo pure lui e riesce a
fermarmi e venirmi di carnevale io
apprezzo sempre degli audio che sono
porti letali e ben di set perfetto 11
anni bc più alta di mercato
il manubrio a un certo punto si mette
verticale e io cado di volano sul
manubrio è fatto male livido nero qui io
di litri e che da quel momento in poi li
ho perso vocalmente la possibilità di
essere b consente biciclette possono
essere bastare soprattutto quelle
elettriche questa estate a procida per
abbia avuto prima curva
mi apro e sono finito sulla bicicletta
ma come si chiudendo sulla bicicletta
che è già sulla bicicletta
sulla bicicletta curvo scivolo non sono
sempre 7 procida che è stufa di questa
piedi presente procida perdona io no ma
perché si sono saputi sembra più facile
la boe diventano scivolosi praticamente
sono finito sul tubo della bici mi sono
aperto suonavano i punti quasi
ascoltiamo un ultimo perché ne ho
abbastanza di noi
2008 14 febbraio san valentino il primo
appuntamento come persona che cupo mi
sentivo da un po al compleanno di
un'amica di tutti sconosciuti sangria
lui si ubriaca devo accompagniamo a casa
ma ho guidato io vomita in continuazione
quindi decido io di accompagnare a casa
lui e portò la sua macchina sotto casa
mia l'indomani mattina non trovo la
macchina quindi non solo ho conosciuto
una persona di esse ubriaca e che mi
lascia sono anche meglio gli hanno
rubato la macchina invece no lory dopo
la sovranità scende giù col secondo
mazzo di chiavi si portano a chi questa
è una figura di merda che ha fatto lui
tutto sbagliato prima appuntamente a san
valentino ho già sentito l'orrore potevi
aspettare il giorno prima un giorno
primo giorno dopo primo appuntamento a
casa di altri quante solitudini si
possono mettere insieme a san valentino
tutto sbagliato ma questo cosa ci
insegna questa cosa cercano secondo te
cosa ci insegna questo odio
in estate certo perché comunque andata
bene esatto quindi cosa che ci insegna
che bisogna rischiare
[Applauso]
in realtà quello che ci insegna questo
audio è che una persona con la quale per
qualcun utile un attrazione che ti piace
se mica casse in mano o recitare inizio
di questo di questo nostro incontro
l'amante navy e intarsi o le direi sotto
sotto ma ti posso dire che sta merda
quando la fai tu e nutella e adesso ce
la posso fare chiudere questo questo
video domani è il giorno del giorno geni
micosi cose al teatro brancaccio yes
fino al terribile mi auguro che vada
avanti per parecchio questo spettacolo
perché necessario nella sua semplice
come l'abbiamo definito ieri con il
primo incontro che abbiamo avuto col
pubblico è una rivoluzione gentile e
credo che di questi tempi ce ne sia
molto bisogno non c'è niente di più
bello quando una bella faccia anche un
bel cuore delle bellissime parole che
qualcun altro scritto per lui
questa cosa ma devo chiudere con una
cazzata grazie mille per essere stato
mio ospite non so quando ci rivedremo ma
prima o poi grazia che ho giocato con
mare ha dato a vedere al cinema anche
l'altro fa teatro ragazzi sono sette gli
ignoranti di merda un bacio di bene ciao